[Music]
you made it weird with Pete Holmes
what's happening weirdos this week's
guest is Joe latrulio reno911 uh
Brooklyn Nine-Nine the man plays a lot
of cops uh he's in super bad he's in the
state and he's incredible here's a
little taste of our conversation you
know like to get a like just a hug yeah
from a male friend can I say incredible
man hugs man hugs there's nothing like a
man there's nothing
there's another one oh my God you smell
great I was worried about like I was
worried about my pitch
he's also a delight he's also incredibly
interesting wonderful fun and this two
hours flew by riff City friend City dare
I say I feel like this is my new friend
we had a lot of fun and genuinely made a
real connection and I'm excited for you
guys to listen in and check it out you
also known from Superbad I love you man
and of course the state I mean don't
forget the state this guy's a legend and
he was so fun to talk to if you want to
see more of me question mark you can see
me I'm on tour I don't tour a lot I
don't tour a lot but I am touring right
now if you want to come uh tickets if
you want to come go to petehomes.com the
next dates coming up are Grand Rapids
San Diego New Orleans Dallas Houston
Milwaukee Madison
Royal Oak Michigan Minneapolis New York
New York and Ridgefield Connecticut I'll
be adding more dates as well
uh but they'll all be on petehomes.com
regardless of when you hear this I also
do a monthly show at Largo the next one
is on March 29th the day before my
birthday for tickets to that if you're
going to be in the LA area always the
highlight of my month go to
largo-la.com and look for the show Pete
Holmes living at Largo and if you want
to support this show why not try Pete's
pick like this one I'm wearing right
here this is my Apollo neuro for those
of you that are watching it on the video
Apollo Nero I wear it on the inside of
my wrist Val wears it on her ankle this
is the product that I think I've turned
more people on to just IRL in real life
than any other and I'm so glad that
they're a sponsor of this podcast
because the Apollo neuro is helping
people cope and recover from stress so
beautifully and without anything
internal in your body it's something you
wear it's a wearable piece of technology
that sends almost sub-perceptual
vibrations directly into your nervous
system because that is the language your
nervous system speaks it basically
simulates the feeling of being held or
hugged it's a wearable digital hug that
can help you relax it can help you sleep
I swear by it when I sleep if I get up
in the middle of the night I rerun the
program lulls me back to sleep if it
only did that it would be incredible but
also helps you focus it helps you create
energy without having more coffee you
can run the energy and wake up program
gets your heart pumping gets you in the
flow wonderful when you're driving
sometimes when I'm getting sleepy when
I'm driving I turn my Apollo on energy
it's just such a wonderful Secret Weapon
It's like finding the fuse box to your
body
for your nervous system help you feel
safe and in control energy and wake up
Social and open for when you're at
parties or when I'm doing stand-up or
honestly when I'm doing this podcast my
apologies often on social and open clear
and focused helps people with symptoms
of ADD helps you focus and dial in
rebuild and recover wonderful for after
workouts but it's also wonderful after
just stressful things like maybe a call
home to the folks meditation and
mindfulness it lulls you and guides you
into deeper and more satisfying
meditation that is one of my favorite
settings and as I mentioned relax and
unwind and sleep and renew it actually
trains your nervous system to cope with
stress better over time the more you use
it the better it works and it is not
woo-woo they don't sell them in crystal
shops this is hashtag science Apollo
neuro was developed by a neuroscientist
and a board-certified psychiatrist
who've been studying the impacts of
chronic stress in humans for over 15
years I'm sorry for nearly 15 years and
Apollo's effects on stress sleep
cognitive performance and Recovery have
been proven multiple clinical trials and
real world studies so it's the real deal
I know a lot of us are dealing with
stress a lot of us are dealing with lack
of energy lack of focus the Apollo neuro
is a wonderful chemical free way to help
your body do what it's capable of doing
and you can get 10 off and show your
support of the show by going to
apolloneuro.com weird for 10 off that's
APO llo
n-euro.com weird for 10 off it's a great
gift it's also a great gift to give
yourself also one of our oldest and
longest running Pizza picks is my I'm
holding it up for the camera and shaking
it for the listeners uh this is on it
Alpha Brain Alpha Brain is a new atropic
I know you hear a lot about new atropics
and frankly I've tried a lot of new
atropics and on it Alpha Brain has been
my go-to for the almost the past decade
now I always have it it's like fish food
for your imagination it gives your body
gives your brain Earth grown ingredient
items that help it concentrate and dial
in it's not a stimulant it's not like
caffeine it doesn't give you any Jitters
or jolts it just gives you the nutrition
that you need to concentrate and what
are you doing I don't I don't know much
about you I don't know what you're doing
in your life but chances are you're
using your brain I wish I had this in
school it would have been so helpful for
tests exams for reading now I just take
it as I always say I take it before a
date with Val just so I'm an engaging
and interesting date I take it every
time before this podcast I take it every
time before I write a script or I have
an important call or do stand-up comedy
it is a noticeable discernible
difference just a feeling of having the
support you need the nutrition you need
in your brain to function at its utmost
I'm going to say at its utmost and you
can give it a try the best way to know
if you like Alpha Brain is to give it a
try and you'll get 10 off and you'll
show your support of the show go to onit
o n n i t.com slash weird you'll get 10
off everything you see on that landing
page use promo code weird at checkout 10
off from everything at onit.com weird
give it a try it's a huge game changer
for me and last but not least I don't
always mention this but we're drinking
uh Nirvana Water Sciences water in all
of these video episodes if you happen to
notice it it's water that supports lean
muscle development improves muscle
performance and Mobility reduces muscle
soreness and boosts recovery boosts
recovery time post exercise because it
has something called hmb in the water
it's incredible that's why we're working
with them the drink the official drink
go to Nirvana Water sciences.com and use
promo code pete20 you get 20 off give it
a try an incredible way to transform
your body and stay hydrated all right
everybody hope to see you out on the
road enjoy this chat with Manu pal Joe
the trulio get into it don't even untie
them just kick them off yeah
to do it how do you undo
undo I mean that's how you undo a shoe
right there you can wear those or not I
just made a choice not to oh I'm gonna
you don't have to I'm not gonna wear
them yeah so what what we were just yeah
I'll just say what we did before we
rolled okay was something that I love
transparency all right Joe is just
saying he's a little stressed about
something not even that interesting in
his uh business life right that you
wanted to dump I wanted a dump before we
began yes and I want to say that every
show first of all hello is this okay how
does this feel pretty good we just had
Rick Glassman on that didn't oh I feel
good that felt great yeah that was a
good that was a good stretch that was
awesome
you ever do yoga and you're like why
don't we stretch all the time yeah it
feels so good it's like a massage you
give yourself but it takes effort
takes a little effort to do it takes a
little too much effort I was doing yoga
for a lot for a while it's yogurt I
don't want you to be embarrassed when
this is released by the way this is
gonna happen a lot yeah but especially
uh uh on these podcasts when I'm kind of
like thinking about what to say I'll
mispronounce words and go on but you but
please well your buddy Ken Moreno yeah
did this pod and confessed that he I
watched it okay foreign
act yes it was one of the more epic I
love it I still have the TV Guide he
gave me but remember he used to say
souvenir instead of souvenir yes which I
found incredible really incredible have
you had a lifelong mispronunciation mine
was mine was Channel I used to say
Channel instead of channel oh I change
the channel oh change the channel
because there is an actual Channel and I
call that the channel
have you ever been on the channel no I
have not no no but I have not no I'm
jumping back to uh the uh
mispronunciations yes I feel like
um like uh hello how do you say the
thing you put on pancakes syrup okay
then I I say the same thing syrup okay
that's how do some people say syrup
syrup syrup syrup yeah it's not syrup
and I'm gonna go farther it's not greasy
it's greasy oh I've never greasy no no I
say greasy greasy someone says that
people say greasy really I think it's a
southern thing and I don't mean to shame
anybody but I don't like uh I don't like
anybody that's as greasy yeah I don't
wanna yeah I want to draw a line in the
sand but I will die on that Hill sure I
like uh don't die first of all what is
um the T100 the T800 is a Terminator
starts with an R robot yeah robot it's
not rubbish
uh a buddy uh uh of mine uh well then
Grant from um uh the state and other uh
incredible shows yeah says Thanksgiving
I don't care for that
but off of that yeah I like how British
people say girlfriend go friend
girlfriend is this your girlfriend or
like the weekend weekend girlfriend yeah
we go girlfriend and weekend weekend
yeah I just had to speak uh Mandarin for
the first time for what just a little
espionage
and has being heard by many people can I
say I'm confident they're not gonna
watch the people that I'm after yeah
they're not after joyful they don't have
time they don't have time you should see
what they're doing I'll just tell you I
don't want to know I'll just I mean it
involves parachutes and that's scary
yeah plausible deniability yes for the
Le trigale am I saying that right well
you know it's funny uh yeah oh that's uh
because I I listened I listened to
carries too did she say your name wrong
no you guys were not well no you guys
went off on my name for a little bit and
we did we did it's all good there's no
no
yeah I would understand like but it's a
term of endearment and I let I let it go
with some people you can do that can I
just say yeah I was just predicting what
past people my might have said you put a
Joe and a low that close to each other a
goofy man and you're not in the room
yeah I might have said Jolo part of it's
my fault part of it is me separating the
first two letters of my last name yeah
because yeah like I take complete it's
ownership of of my name is that your
choice and the trouble well no that's
how it's actually spelled but I could
have like most people just squeeze it
together Ellis Island yourself let's do
it and who I am now but I needed that
capital T I don't know yeah I get it in
a lot of people's iPhones your jlt you
know yeah that yes exactly yeah I mean
here's the kind of summary of my name
because it's maybe the most boring
subject ever I can't wait can I just say
by the way yeah it's not boring ah I
like it thank you it's your name this is
part of the nervousness this bag of
rocks around with you the last name Lo
truglio yeah which is for fun it's fine
no no but it's a lot it's a lot it's a
lot it's a lot thank you SATs this is
part of the nervousness I was talking
about talking about myself and then
specifically my name I'm gonna figure it
out yeah because that's actually great
I'm going to give you a compliment if
you came in here raring to go talking
about like I just can't wait to unload
like I'd like you to feel safe and seen
and heard well but not like just a
donkey j-i-z-z I try not to be too dirty
in the first couple minutes
what about jism
like uh jism like like some some jazz
yeah
if you flip it well yeah yeah yeah
now we're just making sounds if one of
them happens to be we could scat this
whole thing should it be dead
if you hear Ella Fitzgerald scat which
I'm sure as a owner of Apple music
account I'm sure it's come on everyone's
every Christmas lover you might just
hear it uh you do feel bad for the bad
name that that scaten's been given uh
you know what I mean I know when someone
can really do it you're like holy [__]
yeah that's really something but that I
mean the good ones I saw a white guy in
a Barnes Noble in Central Maine Scout
once
and if you haven't seen a Peppa
Peppa Pig
terrible generalization of people in
Maine they just talk like the Pepperidge
Farms or Fred Gwynn from pet cemetery
Milano men Milano
actually you figured out a nice little
uh hack a good way to scat if you can't
think of any just say Pepperidge Farms
cookies
those work yes
Samoa because Samoa isn't what is a a
Samoan Samos a uh a Polynesian native I
believe right and I'm always like I'm
afraid I'm gonna order a Polynesian
native when I really just want that
coconut cookie yeah yeah I mean have you
ever been to Polynesia I've been I've
stayed at the Polynesian a lot of
cookies
um a lot of coconut cookies there a lot
of Coke in here that's where that's
where it comes from the
is it darker in here than it normally is
the cloud cover oh oh oh you still
clouds come over this podcast you still
look great look where were we you're
nervous yeah I I'm like it's a house I
feel so okay good I feel safe but it's
healthy to come in and not want to be
like I can't wait for the world to know
about
yo I tell it's kind of triple run that
is nice that is
I learned how to um cope cope only
recently
with my name so it's all new it's kind
of exciting no I found out it's
pronounced that way from my grandfather
told me that what do you mean uh La
Trulia the g is silent the Trulia and so
this is this is what um I think you and
Carrie were riffing on rightfully so is
that for so long thanks for people whoa
thank you for a lot of people when we're
doing that I'm like he's not gonna hear
this but then no I I well you know I
want to do my preparation for your
Carrie bikini let's make fun of her name
uh keaney she's the biggest she's like
my big sister yeah yeah that was always
the best relationship
um
a lot of them didn't get used not to get
used and believe me those rehearsals
were not easy to be at there was a lot
of upset people a lot of heat a lot of
heat you could cook an egg on the 30s 31
members of the state we needed such a
big room and most of the people weren't
even on the stage and they're not a good
audience because they're just like I
could do that not funny nah better
better recurring character I had a
better recurring character I got Kids in
the Hall on line two that's what they
say
um what were you saying you've coped I
was saying oh no I was just uh getting
back to the name and and why people were
like what is it what's with the name
because I was saying La truglio myself
uh until I was 20. of course and then uh
and then I changed it and you know
changing a name Midstream for those that
are close to you sometimes they don't
like that you know don't change your
horse Midstream yeah
20 years old yeah I have a silent l in
my name Holmes but you kind of say it
homes you don't say homes you can I
won't correct you for home I will
correct you for homos
yeah I like a medicine no it's called
can I have the homeless yes the
Coulee let me ask you this yeah I
listened to you on our friend Michael
rosenbaum's pod oh yeah and you were
about to have a colonoscopy yeah you've
had it I'm clear isn't this fun clear
it's great because the Joe I heard on
that show yeah was about to get one yeah
I'm talking to the better Joe than oh
you're talking about Joe the polyp free
Joe
clean squeaky clean Joe tell me because
I'm 43 which means yeah two years shy of
I still think that's a little young it
can't hurt it can't hurt it can't hurt
well I don't know if you use the right
drugs it won't hurt but what did you do
for your numbing because I know Brian
took I think he took the opioids yeah I
said I just you know I said put me under
it no I think I uh Pro propanol propanol
yeah that's a gas yeah yeah they come
from your butt do they just get the tube
from your butt right right Loops it
right around give them the gas station
just siphon it right out it was right
there and then you pass out because your
own butt smells so bad you pass out and
then mine smells actually wonderful does
it yeah yeah you have a grape okay I
don't wanna wait good nah I don't mind
oh if you're alone though it's an old
Eddie Murphy bed you want to smell your
own part because you want to grade it
you want to know where it is on the
scale my son does that what do you mean
he crazy doesn't grade it but he you
know he'll tell you yeah he'll tell you
it's me oh he wants he claims it yeah
what about in front of your wife we uh
you know you know what's great Beth and
I have we we try not to do it we try not
to do it really to keep the romance
alive yeah I mean that's the struggle
for any married couple but you know uh
well married eight years but together uh
uh but together 20. wow yeah that's
annoying yeah so yeah it sounds like
you're kind of newlyweds but you're like
I've been with this woman yeah at least
exactly and I got a kid who's farting
and smelling it and claiming it and
claiming it it's a long relationship
yeah so you've been together 18 years
and you tried I'm gonna let you know Val
and I do rip it I do she yeah which is
you know exact picture
I don't know what the patriarchy is but
I think on the on the far topic yeah
it's farting in front of her but it's
like a mystery you know I guess I can
try to keep but you know I look you're
not going to get any pushback from me I
did for uh we're talking farts how was
it you took the gas you took the pro
propanol uh yes and I don't remember uh
much yeah it was pretty quick like they
said countdown I got to probably eight
and uh was that embarrassing no you want
to get to six I wanna I
I didn't set a goal before I went in
Mexico I'm getting this is Jason ten
nine and Jason Momoa is next year three
two one zero negative one and he goes
out negative eight wait what is that
what is that he's a man he's a man
oh I see you you're a boy like me okay I
make it to that in nine I see because
I'm ready to pass it you're ready I'm
what does a qualify as I don't know
eight is normal it is normal I'm just
gonna say apparently I talk a lot wow
you're out while I was out really but it
was mainly nonsense I tried to get you
know some specifics and they
wouldn't give me I don't know if it was
mainly nonsense what if you were like
you know my least favorite rest you know
like I'll tell you my favorite cookies
samoas Thin Mints they're like he
doesn't even know that that's a
Polynesian person no he just said a
cookie yeah yeah yeah yeah who knows
what I was saying you should have
recorded it although this is one of my
fears you're dying right so you're
Marion I'm Marion I'm dying I'm in a
hospital yeah that's pretty good yeah
I'd like a a nice old age Hospital yeah
they give you a little druggies and yeah
a little kind of cycle through uh-huh
you know what I mean you say your
goodbyes just to just to have like do
you like the idea of someone like taking
care of you I like bed I like any bed
I'll take it yeah a death bed still the
bed it's still a bed
and it's a bed so much yeah I just need
a bed uh we have is Death Beds hey still
the bed as soon as you die in a bed it's
a good bed take it but I'm worried that
as you go right I'll start saying some
nonsense because you know we're stuck
with our brains all the live long yeah
yeah so you're driving around and every
once in a while you'll just have some
insane and disgusting or yeah let's not
say disgusting but like truly
absurd dream like nonsense comes out in
your brain sure I'm worried about being
really old and then I start going like
Napoleon was a sweet place
isn't that the best isn't that something
to look forward to though I like [__]
yeah you know like it's it's he's like
oh he's getting up there like my yeah
you can get away with a lot my
grandfather uh
silent G silent G he passed away a while
ago from Alzheimer's uh but before he
passed you know when I was visiting him
at the at the center he would say Joe
come here and he'd call me over and he's
like you see you see that uh blonde
nurse over there there was not a blood
nurse there there was like a male nurse
or no one at all and I said yeah he's
like you yes when they close when they
close down the clothes shop they put us
to bed she brings out a keg we all come
we have a party it's great it's a great
time it's like and I'm listening to this
and in my head of course immediately
like oh my my Grandpa's going but
immediately after like this sounds
pretty great if I'm gonna get stuck and
you want to be careful because
Alzheimer's is not great it's terrible
and pain look he could have said that
for the loved ones tortures us when he
said a keg I'm celebrating the way that
your grandfather's brain decided yes he
was in a party he was in some type of
kegger yeah and you know like I did they
have keggers and you know he was born in
35 years
yeah but yeah you gotta have cupcakes
bring in the bathtub gin the Gin still
we have
and the cupcakes are 100 flour
unflavored flour because we've got all
these licorice rips whips coming in
I like liquid and a case of Charlotte
ruses
[Music]
who wants a slow gin fizz in a liquor
licorice rib these are hard we do it all
here but he thought she rolled out a
cake so he even kind of modernized his
fantasy yeah yeah and it was it was
amazing in that way like wow this is a
terrible disease but if I'm gonna go
crazy I guess this is the way to do it
live in this I miss you well did you
hear on uh NPR that's National Public
Radio I've heard of it yeah you gotta
donate they'll give you a bag sure
um Mike Birbiglia ah we already familiar
we were laughing about I called you Joe
Birbiglia for no reason I said Thank You
Fresh Off Broadway exactly yep these are
the riffs we'll reheat them we're here
for you guys everybody on NPR they did a
thing about how improv improvisers and
Alzheimer's the principles of improv
help when dealing with people with
Alzheimer's so imagine I have
Alzheimer's and in my uh you know my own
reality yeah that nurse brings out a keg
right you can say no they don't that's
not true there isn't even a nurse over
there they were making the argument that
the principles of improv are actually
more comforting more soothing because
what would happen is if you yes and did
yeah one of two things will happen one
you've just sort of comforted them and
let them know that their authority over
reality even though we kind of know it's
not right is right yeah there's a
comfort to that yeah or two oh I'm gonna
forget the second point two they slowly
put together that it's absurd what
they're saying oh they come to the
conclusion away they're coming around to
to figuring out really changed my life
yeah that's amazing yeah and and what a
great piece of advice I I you know I
believe I was adhering to it when I was
talking I was like oh yeah really wow
how long does that last you know that's
great yeah I'd love to be there yeah I'd
love so I can't make it tonight but this
is a little sad sometimes I catch myself
my parents don't have Alzheimer's but I
do that with my parents anyway like
they'll be like I realized that instead
my mom will say when will you come visit
or something and I'll have just visited
them will be like when are you going to
visit and instead of being like well I
just visited like why are you always
doing this you're guilting me or
whatever right you just say it's like
good improv you just go like I would
love to I really hope we can oh that's
great just jump to it yeah I I don't
actually think she's logically saying
necessarily let's plan a trip right
she's saying do you want to visit me
right and when you just give it do I
feel perhaps do I feel are you do you
still need me do you need me am I still
useful am I in your life will I see you
again before I go like I I get a big
change for me you just go oh that would
be amazing and uh Mark duplass when he
did this podcast when my mom talks about
the old days when I was little and how
much she enjoyed that you just go like
oh it'd be so great if we could go back
to that it was such a special time yeah
instead of being like you you are
violating my boundaries I'm a grown man
right like I do not and finalize me yeah
you can do that and Lord knows I've done
a version of that right I didn't yell it
but you can also just go like that was a
magical time it's always the shoved it
right it's always a shift like I feel
like the older that I get trying to
navigate those feelings of of of
not attacking someone but just being so
riled up by someone yeah to to be like
who said this to me um I can't remember
if someone says man you learned so much
more about a person if you just listen
to them I'm saying I'm stating the uh
the obvious but there's like you know
disagreements are are such a way to
under to understand how you feel about
something to kind of make someone else
feel like they're they're heard as
opposed to like well what I think is
this to your point you're like oh yeah
oh okay I never thought of it we call
that green lights we do that on green
lights there's been a lot of times on
this podcast where someone says
something that I like fervently disagree
with yeah but it's so much more
open or spacious to just kind of go with
it and and not be so precious that your
opinions will evaporate in the sight of
another opinion I feel like that's a
that's a fear that's dominating most of
the culture that's sort of the time
we're in isn't it yeah it's like all of
our beliefs are like livers in elevators
of hospitals it's like don't breathe on
it don't breathe on it
don't infect it yeah keep it in the
cooler keep it protected yeah
everybody wear the booties where the
booties over my
I get it I I know what it's like to have
your not feel safe but once we get past
a certain level of Civility it is
refreshing to have people I'm drawn to
people that just kind of like these are
the ABCs of me baby same because you
know well it's also like how secure do
you feel in what you actually believe
well that's it you know and and not
stubborn with how you feel like I
think this way because I'm thoughtful
and reflective and have been thinking
about this idea for a while and have
like looked at it from all sides and
I've landed here yeah I feel pretty
secure here now someone may kind of hold
up or or point a little path at me like
oh actually I'm over here a little bit
but I'm not gonna fall over where I am
right now right I'm not gonna trip where
I am right now can't we go gradually if
you're on that horse yeah I it's funny
I'm currently reading some stuff that
I'm not sure I agree with it's spiritual
stuff I won't I won't I won't I will
that's for later that's later right
later later yeah but but the point is
I'm I'm going into a thought system that
isn't necessarily super optimistic like
it's not always telling me what I want
to hear but I'm like I said to someone I
said to my friend Shane Moss the other
yesterday I was like it's almost like
I've been parented so well spiritually
that I feel safe enough to look at
things that are a little bit more
um Bleak like like just to let you know
what I'm talking about like thought
systems that are like reality isn't
actually happening it's kind of like a
dream or a dance or a play there's
nothing wrong we can still honor it but
like it can be a little frightening to
go like maybe it's not ultimately real
but the reason I'm okay at looking at
ideas like that or entertaining them
literally just entertaining them right
because I am on my horse that goes like
I'm a beloved child of God I belong here
this isn't a mistake I'm safe we're okay
yeah but because of that Foundation I
feel safe going into like a weirder
shadowy or path well you have you have
someone with you right exactly but yeah
start with this isn't real yeah yeah
yeah even when I say it's not real this
is a very real experience for me I'm not
going to deny that we're having like a
very rare experience I'm just going like
how far down can you go before you go
like it's really just it's really just
uh it's really just programming binary
code yeah yeah whatever go to fight he
had one was the world of Duality that's
that's a perfect way to put it yeah
that's what I just wanted you to know
what I did bore you no no no I don't
think you feel bored but I did say I
won't bore you and then yes I did yes
I'm interested in stuff in talking about
stuff like that we don't have to dive in
I know that's a little bit later no
really it tends to be the end it tends
to be there yeah but we can get into it
whenever we want here's here's a more
fun way to to touch on it ever see a
ghost
or because a lot of people haven't seen
a ghost anything unexplainable happen in
your life something like a psychic tell
you something or a dream that predicted
the future or like a place you go you
always get this weird feeling
that you felt like is still a part of
your life yeah that you know I've never
I'll start with the I've never seen a
ghost and believe and very much believe
in a lot of energy uh around us uh and
and
um it's one one face right here which is
like yeah just thank you [__] finally
thank you thanks Joe that means a lot
I've just been feeling invisible for so
long I'm not seen you don't know what
it's like to be living as a dead thing
that died in 1901 hanging out party
specific well ah I fell and well oh man
it was the most embarrassing way to die
you look good still I mean you look very
much like my friend Pete holmesan well
that's the form I'm taking
oh man well that worked out well that's
how often it happened back then yeah
this guy's falling as well I mean he's
uh luckily he made it out looks like I
don't know I don't know he's still
around I feel I haven't um that's a good
question I I don't uh I haven't seen I
know something weird has happened to me
before and nuns jumping that's what I
mean it's hard it's hard to find I
realized I didn't have an answer to that
question everybody knows this it listens
to us except every time I stay at my
mom's house the ghost of my mom's cat
jumps on the bed and it's every single
time it's it's it's the most reliable so
I was a person going around going like
nah but like sometimes they just get
deleted yeah I sometimes think our
brains are looking out for us and going
like that's sometimes something like
I'll tell you this or I'll ask you this
does this make sense to you that's my
question sometimes I'll have I have
memories of something happening and it's
so weird that I make a choice to just go
like let's just let that go it might be
as simple as a sound in your house yeah
just like if it happens again yeah
I don't mean like a bell look into it
then I'll look into it we're jingling
chains I just mean like we do it all the
time life is so weird and we're just
like let's just let it go
um there was uh so at my house I have a
uh in my garage like I transformed with
my office it's a separate structure is
the point of this yeah freestyle story
and I'm we're in the main house and um
I'm I'm uh my son is uh I kind of
remember this right my son is we're
talking to my son about
something and he said
I'm gonna forget her name let's say her
name is like Sasha she's like well
that's not what Sasha says and we're
like who's Sasha and he's like well
Sasha is the like a ghost the woman that
I saw here before I saw her in your
office oh no and I and I I S and I'm
like what does she look like and he said
she has like like white hair and like a
dress and I mean and you know like but I
mean
thank you for the well you were close
Eli you were close
hand yes yes it's less scary when it's
mine and he gave us the name of Sasha
and then the last name whatever it was
and my wife wait he gave you the last
name he gave yeah which I can't remember
but he gave me a first and last name and
we googled this name and this name was
this
woman from old Hollywood that had bright
like blonde looking white hair and was
like a like a like a burlesque dancer
um that had it didn't say died in some
mysterious way but just the the the
point of the story is the picture that
came up was so much like what he said
that we were just like two point we're
just gonna let this go yeah we're just
gonna let it go my prompt unlocked yeah
very good ghost story yeah that that
happened and I can't handle this and
nothing has happened in that office
that's weird but but it's almost scarier
that it hasn't because he's like I saw
her in your office not in the house yeah
she's in the office
um where I'm most did it have to be
where Dad's hanging out alone yeah yeah
couldn't it have been sending my emails
yeah couldn't have been in a communal
area that's right maybe or even in the
yard you know
you could have a ghost couldn't we be an
outside ghost by the way what if we get
to a point where ghosts are confirmed as
a thing and there are people going like
can we get these ghosts in the house
look at what we used to say in 2023 keep
the ghosts in the yard yeah keep they
don't deserve a little heat keep the
ghost in the yard they're already cold
they always make things colder when
they're yeah exactly right you know and
in the summer they'll be fine by the way
who was it there's somebody on this pod
that was like in the future
I and I think there's a very good chance
they might be right that they'll be
artificial intelligence and they'll look
back on the history of Robotics in our
country in our world and they'll be like
they used to just keep us in their
pockets right next to their ding dongs
right and now that and farting on us you
know it won't be that but there will be
some version of like
what what and it's weird to get into
this because of course there's like
reparations for slavery I'm not trying
to be cute I'm trying to say that
there's a potential that the callousness
that we go Alexa
like this like yeah old we didn't care
the real time off right or or just kind
of immediate gratification yes I can be
like that's why we got rid of our Alexa
Leela started being like yeah play Milan
or whatever never got one of those
because I was
paranoid about you know they're
listening they're listening anyway on
the phone like I really do believe I
mean for for you know an Alexa or any of
those for me is like a brilliant kind of
move by any any company agency or spy
agency like we can just get him to pay
us can I tell 300 bucks and we can have
a mic in their room yeah in their house
in every house and every room of the
house it's like a pretty can I tell you
I had a bit about this Joe you're
ripping a thought right oh really oh
they we they put a listening device in
our house
in exchange for something we already had
we already had music who was going
around going like if only I could voice
automate music I would have music back
in my life right it's just a slightly
yeah who was like oh I I pushed a button
this is I don't want to take a nap I
want to order people around I want
people to do something for me I want to
feel some power and some control yeah
and that's when the future Robo lawyer
and this will be exhibit zero one one
zero one one see that'll be considered
like a bad taste joke I think we're in
trouble with the AI I Gotta Be Honest
Jack and I know part of this is like old
crank Luddite dude but man this is just
bad news it just doesn't make any sense
to me why we need to have a computer
telling us writing essays and telling
I'm already sounding people that was
fine but like it's too we could ask EBT
to write a rant against itself in The
Voice voice of Aging comedian Joe
letrulio well that I'd be into now now I
get it never mind
what would YOLO truglio say what would
Jolo trulio say oh first of all it says
I'd like to clarify that the g is silent
second of all do we really do we really
need it I'm I'm with you it's one of the
strangest things and I think our Freud's
would have something to say about man's
unconscious desire for annihilation like
yeah I I remember talking to my
self-sabotage type of thing yeah just
even worse than self-sabotage might be
like ruining an audition or something or
breaking up younger person that actually
was great for you I actually mean like a
real yearning for Oblivion like just
like complete get us out of here right
and what what supports that is on one
hand we're writing movies about how AI
is surely going to see us as a festering
virus destroying the resources of our
host planet right and will be replaced
by robots that's what we're doing with
our left hand and with our right hand
we're making those robots right right
what's going on but it is it speaks to
why people
um pick your poison drink a ton
eat a ton yeah uh do uh risky things
motorcycles hand gliding free base
jumping free Basin all these things
speak to
an often overlooked energy that is at
play which is this quiet like
this could we could we could make this
all go away like yeah I don't mean
suicide I mean like Benjamin I say this
but can we I are we too past are we too
deep are we too far too deep and it's
because we have music from Alexa and
then yeah and chat GPT is so fun
you know it's so interesting what
technology
has not been weaponized yet yeah or
sexualized or sexualized yeah like
photocopy this is the old Seinfeld bed
photocopy everyone puts the button on
the photocopier it was right there it
was a glass camera for an ass
they designed it to make not our
secretary's job he's high enough to hop
up on there that's right yeah wouldn't
it have been three feet higher you would
have prevented a hole that's it or or
you load it and it goes it shoots up it
does its business up there yeah just
don't put it anywhere near it on the
bottom of the thing we can't get to it
put it on the bottom put them on the pot
it up cover it up load it in yeah why do
I need to be able to see the light go
you know when you put it like me anvil
on top of it that's hard to lift thank
you yeah that a robot has to better
robot has to live a lawyer in the future
would say did you ever ask the robot how
he felt but we do sexualize and we do
weaponize everything like microwave
technology was developed by the Army
like every time you use your microwave
the technology was made as a weapon
which seems weird but then someone said
to me so is fire like fire Cooks food
too and fire is like one of the original
the original technology yeah it was one
of the it was the original technology
but it was also like let's now that we
have this let's burn our enemies
like one of the worst things when when
people are battering just the nature of
man battering ram a castle and they pour
the tar uh the mo or the molten lead is
that what it was yeah the molten lead
can you
I'm glad we don't live back then I mean
that's the worst time right is anyone
when you ask someone hey what what era
do you want to go back to does anyone
say the Middle Ages the Dark Ages no
it's so you can imagine do you think
they knew then like man no one's going
to want to wish to come back here
in the future no one's coming here this
is it we just lost out bad timing on our
part even movies one out of 35 or
middle-aged movies yeah because you
can't see that many people with no ex
well they're a Medieval Age there's a
lot of middle-aged movies out there well
that's I suppose that's true the last
one I watched was the last duel and I
was like these people were like taking
rats like Tylenol they're like you're
having to eat it eat this rash just like
no as an Elixir and Ryan holiday to this
part and he was like remember the Dark
Ages were after
I'm gonna sound stupid here I wouldn't
know it's gonna be my souvenir yeah I
don't know if it's the enlight I don't
know when the enlightenment is yeah but
there was a time of we were doing good
as a people and then all the libraries
were burned and then we fell into the
Dark Ages like it wasn't like surprise
surprise men and then nights it was like
when all the education's gone that we go
into the Dark Ages okay it was it was
caveman a bunch of other stuff then it
was like ancient Greece and logic and
math and all this stuff and after that
is the [__] Dark Ages where
Matt Damon in a mullet is riding it Adam
Driver with a jousting needle I think uh
you know not to get super Bleak but I
we're kind of their forces at work now
in this culture that want to welcome a
new Dark Age which is a lack of uh
intellectualism and a lack of being
smart or an opinion or a science or
application the toothpaste back in the
tube though I hear you yeah and now
we're gonna have healthy discourses we
were saying great great because once you
oh the sun came out once you sort of
your point what is the word you just
make it so easy to find out most things
I guess now that that's a pretty hairy
string to pull I'm saying the internet
has given us access to so many ideas
like I want to know what entropy was
right I just wanted a refresher on
entropy you can just type it in your
computer and it'll tell you yeah I don't
think we can go back to like it's God
melting ice you know what I mean like
you can't no no you can't I see you're
saying like those forces are in check
because because it's been what's the
word there's a word that means like
given to all the people uh there's a
fancy word yeah I don't know I get I
guess I'm thinking just politically
political entities right that want that
uh uh well it sure was easier to control
people in the Dark Ages yeah right yes
and if you don't have good medicine and
you don't have good education people
tend to become a lot more tribalistic
they become a lot more superstitious I
mean that's what sucked about those
times there was a time you go to the
doctor
and then be like you know cowboys would
go to the doctor and then be like burn a
little Jasmine on the back of a dime and
then bite it off while it's still hot
but it has to be raining yeah you know
what I mean it's like that yeah we we do
live in that we Val and I were just
re-watching White Lotus because we have
a four-year-old so I think we missed a
lot of stuff and there's a part where
the very attractive uh British man did
you watch White Lotus I did I saw both a
very attractive British man yeah in the
first season second season second season
oh yeah there is a very attractive
British man in the first season yeah
manager yeah yeah he's very handsome
very handsome
dreamy like he's cockneys like yeah he's
getting a bit of fun yeah yeah yeah you
know and uh Val and I both agree that
he's a Dreamboat and he at one point
says to the his the girl that he's
dating she's like I just want to be
satisfied and he's like can you imagine
living in the Middle Ages everyone's
just tearing each other apart right like
if you can't be satisfied in this time
yeah you'll never be satisfied
I mean that's what makes that show so
brilliant yeah is like that's a really
good it's not the whole picture right
but you could say
but you are just sitting on a boardwalk
eating a gelato right now right you know
what I mean yeah yeah yeah and yeah yeah
we get overwhelmed with all the info and
I I honestly I'm being real I don't know
how much is healthy to deny
healthy to deny what what's coming at
you it comes to you and I could spend 45
minutes to four hours Googling
everything that happened yesterday in
fact it would take way longer than four
hours sure would it would take a week
sure would take a month yeah to find
every terrible thing that happened
yesterday yeah yeah that was reported
probably I don't even know maybe six
months right a long time you're saying a
lot a little so you're denying denial is
a part of life it's and it's a huge tool
yeah and the White Lotus really seems to
be uncovering what we're denying yeah
like the the number of microorganisms
that we kill you know somebody that you
know stayed away from Mead and and all
these things because I wanted to not
kill things it's like yeah but you're
denying these other things that you kill
or the practices of the companies of the
things that you buy and the things that
they kill or leather or or the rats that
get sucked up when they're harvesting
kale you know like what about these guys
you know so there's always going to be
some denial and it does seem to be a
bell curve there's a there's a great
level of denial and then there's the too
much where you become right well denial
is certainly uh
needed to often you know uh protect from
the pain yeah and the fear yeah yeah you
and I you know we live in there's always
my example but there could be an
earthquake right now you could have an
aneurysm right waiting for that for a
while yeah The Californians California
Californians now when I moved to LA they
were like there's a 99.95 chance it'll
happen before I worried about that too
and I was like Wow but do you but
there's a great comfort in that it's
like we also don't know you don't know
man we also don't know yeah could it may
not happen for another 100 years the way
we think about the planet is the way we
think about our bodies like it's the
same interest same strategy it's like
yeah you could have an aneurysm you
could have some rare I look like John
Ritter so when John Ritter died of that
like rare heart thing that no one saw
coming yeah I was like yeah it haunted
me even more and that could happen but
in the same way we deny the probability
of This Disaster or This Disaster This
Disaster and even when you see sometimes
on the far right extreme denial of of
certain uh things coming down the
pipeline you see that also a lot of
times in the body practice like it's
like I'm also denying dating this
yeah it's all how you do everything is
how you do anything yeah well it's yeah
how your your world view your approach
to
right to health and I actually think I
tried to do a bit about this for a while
that I was like the Republicans and I
you know what I mean by that I don't
mean moderate Republicans I mean like
extreme Republicans do have us beat on
that sort of like shut up get over it
get over it I'm not saying that's
healthy as a as a whole sure but you do
need a little shut up get on the
motorcycle
well I think a part of it is
is just you know uh taking
accountability for your own fear right
so if you're saying shut up you could
say to yourself all right just uh I'm
I'm anxious now or I'm I'm presenting a
a fear or or why why am I you know why
am I acting like this or saying that so
I agree with with that in a way right um
but like there's a there's a good level
of shut up but there is a bad level
that's what you're getting for sure and
I and I think that uh you know I think
it's important to um
it's for for people to understand that
they really are in control of their own
mental health and their own
um this may be stating the obvious but
like their their own happiness you just
it's I agree and so if and you got to
get the right level of shut up and you
don't want to hurt other people correct
because that's gonna well I feel like
the shut up I shave I like this term
shut up is for my close friends and my
family you're like hey man come on [__]
up or because I know we're gonna say
that they love me they care about me
they're looking out for me they know I
have the strength to do that you know
yeah I agree and I don't stand by this
this is just a joke but I was like as a
liberal Democrat we do have a lot of
like but but I agree yeah
and they do I I agree and this is a huge
generalization shut up is like Dad
energy and like don't forget your code
on Halloween even though it ruins your
outfit right is is again it's I'm not
saying it's just Mom energy in the
traditional archetype I understand
there's lots of different moms and lots
of different for sure and lots of
different Arrangements of that those
energies but that is what I wish we
could find the the Nuance of somebody
that goes like sometimes I'll give you
an example like when I was a kid I never
wanted to go on roller coasters but I
had my own shut up that helped me and
then I got on and then I loved roller
coasters there you go but if I like you
don't wanna
but I was I'm also a very sensitive kid
if somebody had tried to tell tell me
yeah shut up yeah I would have been
troubled by that I I don't know where
coddling begins yeah and where well
again I think part of it is like does
this person have the right to kind of do
they know me well enough well that's it
to tell me you know how to act because
it would have been my brother that would
have been like or it would have been a
silent pact I had with my brother that I
wanted to impress my brother which is
why are you where are you and your kids
your your siblings but uh I'm the oldest
I have one younger brother yeah it's
interesting you feel like the younger
one benefited from from having you
around
um maybe a little bit yeah maybe a
little bit uh my parents were pretty
um liberal and open with both of us and
and um you know I didn't get a lot of or
he didn't get a lot of what am I trying
to say he got what I got you know you
know he was treated uh you know as
openly as as I was okay yeah I'm saying
obviously that was a leading question
because I just by by virtue of having a
slight he's too old two years older than
me okay a slightly older person who's
therefore a little bit braver than me or
a little bit he's doing things I wanted
to like impress him it helped me to have
a slightly older kid around okay even if
my brother wasn't saying shut up yeah I
was like well he's he's doing it he's
skateboarding or yeah yeah he's biked
down the stairs it's just the one just
the one okay what does your brother uh
do he's in on the other side of the
business uh uh behind he's a events
coordinator for stars I'm actually going
to uh his party for the premiere of
party down which is happening tonight
out of that as of this tape
because you're in the new party down I'm
not but I'm a supporter
why are you working on their uh their
parade that's actually kind of funny
agents have a lot of shut up like in the
in the same way that chefs have a lot of
shut up like we're like don't boil a
lobster and chefs are like shut up yeah
I know how to do it and your agent calls
and goes like ciao needs a double wide
trailer right so you can just go around
and be oblivious in the same way that
the president regardless of the gender
of the president has a lot of that shout
out dad energy it's like I'm gonna go in
and figure out this war or yeah yeah all
this stuff you don't want to do so we
can just keep eating ice cream and and
sometimes farting or not farting in
front of our partners that's correct you
know I I think you know
I love your your analogy there with the
uh with the president uh thing because
it's the dad of the country which is why
there's so much resistance I think to
have a female president yeah but I I was
I was well otherwise I do not agree with
I do not agree with you
on another podcast you know you feel
like presidents should just like kind of
do you vote for a president I vote for a
president for him to kind of just do the
job and I don't want to hear about it I
don't I don't want to hear you brag
about it I don't want to hear you
complain about it yeah I don't even know
this goes for all of them like I don't
want to do to win I voted for you to do
it and just make sure everything keeps
running it's the same as the president
of high school the dumb senior that
wants to be president but you seem
really into this like you want to work
for you yeah all right Reese Witherspoon
you can have meetings on Friday of your
election and I you know what man I've
been to a lot of fancy restaurants and
I've been on a lot of fancy vacations
there's no amount of that lifestyle that
would make it worth it to go in the
situation room and discuss what to do
with like a country that's being invaded
no no no thank you I don't know what's
going on I I and I don't think it's as
cool like when I'm watching like a
sports documentary or something an
accustomed Bill Clinton I'm like it's so
funny that they become like folksy yeah
Jimmy Carter or whatever or you see
Obama in these things and it's like oh
yeah cute the Aging president I'm like
these people all of them
both sides were like deciding which
thousands would die like that was their
job yeah the Arbiter of reality in a
huge way in a huge way it's so weird
that we're like but what do you think
about cotton candy Bill Clinton
did you save the turkey this
Thanksgiving yeah yeah exactly we we
whitewash it when really it's a job
or or like Martin Sheen and West Wing
you know like we want it to be this like
noble thing and I'm sure there is some
element of that but it's also like this
very I think I think that part is
similar to like for people that aren't
in the the show business thinking that
it's all glamor like oh you're in that
movie or you go to premieres and they
miss the other 99.9 it's interesting
yeah and so the president you have this
idea of like oh he's Noble and he meets
with heads of state and he's the
president that has this right all the
cool stuff man there is so much [__]
and scary [__] that these guys well
let's bring that to you it's like you're
a recognizable comedian but like what
are the things something else you said
on Rosie's podcast was like the struggle
is real and I was like of course it is
what are some of the misconceptions like
if you look at your one sheet of your
life it's like oh he's been in all these
different things but I know that there's
months in between there's no doubt tell
me what it's like tell me what people
don't know about being the president of
Comedy coming
very kind but I'm not
um I love that I assumed that you were
saying it was the president no I did
um you heard the Riff right I did okay
you Alzheimer's me I I
the biggest part of uh the biggest
struggle that I had with all of it was
um using my time wisely when I wasn't
doing what I loved to do so for me it
was figuring out time management uh in
terms of creating something like I feel
like
you know one tenant of my life is like
be a Creator and not a destroyer that's
that's very important to me in in all
levels and and so if you are a Creator
then when you have time do that
um right draw
and so
um for the longest time I was kind of
looking outside for comparing like is
this person working is that person
working yeah um and so am I hustling
enough this is not this is very common
for most actors most comedians people
never admitted to my satisfaction I'm
like the number of times I've got I try
to stay off Instagram but the number of
times I just go to someone's profile to
just see how many followers they have
which by the way is why they let you see
how many followers people yeah yeah it's
a whole other it's a few other things
why should I feel ashamed that I'm
checking it's one of the things they've
made available to check yeah and let's
be real it wouldn't be as fun if you
didn't see the score yeah and this is
what's true I mean that's a whole
separate conversation which we could
talk about yeah that that idea of
followers and and accounting that right
because you're counting jobs but I'm I'm
talking about jobs or if not jobs
um where they are in their career which
is the biggest mistake make of all
because everyone has their own timeline
you know and that's really true and
that's very hard to accept when you're
in your 20s you know when you're younger
and you're like what and I'm impatient
by Nature anyway as a person I struggle
with patients
um and so it's like real doubly hard for
me to like let it just come let it just
come to me like even for example even
um you know with Brooklyn ending I
haven't really worked on I've had little
things here and there but I haven't
worked in like well over a year and
almost two years yeah and you know and I
have to kind of now I've been doing I've
worked on a movie since then um but
really I've been available to work on
something like 18 months yeah and I'm
like what is going on I see you in a
room with a rotary phone on a pedestal
and we slowly push him going through a
Rolex I hurt myself today
but I know what it's like yeah did you
hear that Gene Hackman I heard Gene
Hackman in some interview and I just
couldn't believe it Gene Hackman a man
who for since like 1973 yeah has Tarzan
swung from Vine Divine and each Vine is
a movie
said I think when he was doing Tenon
bombs or something he was like uh uh he
had just come off another movie yeah but
he was like every time a movie raps I'm
convinced it's the last time oh yeah and
that's the nature also I think that's
you know for actors that is kind of your
existence you know
um well it certainly is your specialness
addiction you're only as yeah you're
only as special as the last thing that
told you you're special that's that's
the trick yeah and it's also trying to
break down some myths that you're told
early on in your acting career like you
know all you need to do is get that one
scene in a in a movie that's a big hit
and and away we go right who did that
all you need is a sitcom that really
lands and goes is syndicated and goes
for eight years and then you're golden
did that all you need is a couple like a
couple of good campaigns
um ad campaigns and then you're go like
Gateway yeah okay Gateway uh wiener
schnitzel yeah and so yeah but but all
of those things you realize that no one
knows what the [__] they're talking
about you know in terms
what is the secret to a career that just
keeps on going job to job job to job
yeah like that just doesn't happen in
this business that's the reality of it
you know right right you know let's
let's keep on this conversation we're
gonna go to the mid rolls it's
fascinating and I have a lot of thoughts
about it okay and we'll see if we can
figure out human happiness oh
we'll be back I don't know how many ads
there are it's either one minute or two
minutes but just [__]
sent you an ad listen to an ad guys it
[__] pays Katie look at her
look at her maybe you'll learn something
these cameras I'm talking into you know
what those cost we'll be right back
this episode is brought To Us by our
friends at p-y-m I'm holding right here
these are the original mood chews they
are support for overwhelm anxiety and
stress and they're Citrus flavored they
are really tasty I tried these uh I
found them online and it tried them with
Val and the next day after one use I
bought some for my mom my brother a
couple other family members I was like
oh my God this is it this is what I've
been looking for that natural
non-psychoactive
non-addictive something you can take
simply you just eat it it's delicious
and it supports your body p-y-m prepare
your mind is a chew that helps you
manage feelings of stress anxiety and
overwhelm wonderful when you're feeling
worried stressed out or as we say on the
Pod you have a bee in your belly and you
just can't focus you can't do what you
need to do and if you're like me and you
want to avoid Pharmaceuticals it's one
wonderful to have these natural Gaba
l-theanine and radiola Rhodiola radiola
it's it's it doesn't matter if I can say
it or not I feel it it gets in my system
and it helps me just ease into whatever
it is I need to do it's not like a
sedative it doesn't like knock me out or
make you sleepy it's something I take in
the morning to help me face those
sometimes overwhelming things that you
need to get done in the day it is uh I
take them at the start of my day I also
take them at the end of the day it's a
wonderful way to take the edge off and
ease into your evening how it works is
it's comprised of proven amino acid
complexes and adaptogens that help
support your ability so it's helping
your organic ability to manage and
tolerate stress anxiety and overwhelm
it's just giving you those nutrients
that you need to give you that little
boost to get over that hill and do what
you need to do with less stress less
fear less anxiety and overwhelmed they
also make a wonderful product that I
love called mood magnesium it's
formulated by neuroscientists and
nutritional psychiatrists it includes
three magnesiums with the most evidence
to support their effects on stress and
sleep magnesium l-theanate l-theanate
malate and glycinate Incredibly
effective to help you fall asleep faster
sleep throughout the night and wake up
feeling rested 70 or 75 percent of
Americans are deficient in magnesium so
it's just a wonderful thing to get into
your diet anyway but it does help me
fall asleep and stay asleep it's
delicious easy to use Yuzu flavored
power so both of these two things the
original mood chews here and mood
magnesium Pym is on a mission to end the
stigma surrounding mental health and to
make better moods accessible to us all
and a percentage of their profits one
percent goes towards mental health
nonprofits including the one bring
change to mind it's a gentle effective
and natural way to give your body the
nutrition it needs to fight off stress
and I'm so happy to say it absolutely
works it's wonderful to have a new
natural Ally in my corner for those of
us that are dealing with these feelings
of overwhelm it's such a great like I
said non-addictive non-psychoactive Ally
to help us deal with so many so many of
us are dealing with these feelings I'm
so glad Pym is here to help our bodies
and to support this show so you can
support your body and support the show
by going to
youcanpym.com weird and use promo code
weird for 15 off either the mood
magnesium or the original mood shoes
that you can
pym.com weird and promo code weird for
15 off thank you prepare your mind thank
you Pym all right let's get back to Joe
the trulio
okay we're back we're instantly for you
and I we're instantly back thanks to
everybody who thanks for listening to
all of that Listening to All Those ads
and isn't this just an ad for our way of
thinking it is it's an ad for friendship
it's an ad for friendship use code weird
for 10 off your friendship which
actually means it's nice
for friendship I actually wrote down
friends because you're a little bit
older than me but we're both dads yeah
we're both Showbiz [__]
we're both formerly
collaborating meaning
let me tell you I used to make I still
make sketches but not as often my quick
my first introduction to you which I
loved was you working with my wife Beth
Dover on the Batman shorts there you go
and and I I loved it which are hilarious
and I love them and from the get-go
thank you very much the bat suit is
right over there it really is it's in a
box over there because we didn't have
anywhere to put it we're we're sort of a
mom and pop I didn't mean I didn't mean
to break you up yes of course she was
wonderful those things are so fun and
then as I've aged there's just less of
that because now you're doing shows if
you're if you're fortunate yeah you're
working on TV shows and and that part of
your life becomes a little bit more
compartmentalized meaning I spend less
time in comedy clubs less time with
other comedians yeah other Pirates and I
spend less time making sketches because
we just everybody's busy yeah doing
different things and I really was
curious as a dad and a comedy person how
do you do with friends no wrong answer I
mean how do I like are you good at being
um I don't think I'm as good of a friend
as I could be which is to say
I need to work on uh reaching out more
because I when I'm with a person I
listen and I'm present and I love them
and celebrate but like that's not all it
takes to be a good friend like if you're
you know you need to initiative you have
to initiate like your brother of
planning events yeah you do yeah you do
you do you it's it is an a do you have
to play an active role and and what that
does and what's what um what's hard
about that is that you often have to
narrow down who do you want to be part
of your life act because you can't uh it
you know be friends with everyone that
you knew and we're friends along the way
you get older and as you get older and
you don't want to like it's just too
much you want people to kind of know the
the specific you I feel like the people
that know your memories are the ones
that like I really want to kind of be
around the ones that you know that's I
have a lot of other co-conspirators in
building the Joe that is based on the
things that have already happened yes
you don't have to fill them in they
already yeah yeah I do want to jump on
that because I I think you bring up a
great point with men in general and
their outlet and venue to show affection
and feel real like love and affection
with other men yeah because I don't
think a lot of men have are lucky enough
to have that agree like I have a group
of guys
um some in the business some not like in
New York I'm gonna see some of the sweet
some of them this weekend and we talk
about this all the time like how lucky
we are when
um perhaps one of them has experienced
death in the family one is having down
the dumps in their career another maybe
has an illness or a loved one who has an
illness and this idea of
not being vulnerable and not being able
to be vulnerable for me it sucks like
you you you you need that and it's so
rare because of many reasons men in
particular need to be lone wolfs and
tough and strong and on their own and
provide and competitive and protect you
know this is where we hunker down on our
families and we're like a wolf is you
know what I mean wolves don't go yeah
going like I can beat you in a race but
the wolf does go and eat the food yeah I
mean if it finds it yeah and and and
then part of what part of what helps the
wolf
is that you realize the older you get
that there's abundance there's just
there's plenty for everyone there really
is again and that was the thing in early
in my career that like you got that and
I'm I'm not gonna be able to get that
it's already taken right he's already
done it she's already done it right
right and it wasn't just there yes it
was your no yeah this is this is Super
Soul Sunday I'm sorry I just turned into
Super Soul
it's Oprah's podcast I'd be so lucky
yeah it just seemed like a moment though
well I mean the fact is that a lot of
these topics can be kind of dismissed or
looked at as cheap
um but it's I I do feel it's important I
feel like uh I really want to be clear
that that's not what I was doing no you
okay yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yes
conversation no no no no no no this
group of men that are there for one
another yeah I just said their yes is
your no right no no no I I was referring
to the Oprah as long as you feel safe to
continue because I'm very interested so
you have a group of men now that and
yeah and and I I feel that's lacking in
uh many uh male friendships how did it
happen
some I knew since I was uh you know 14
um and then the rest we were at a card
game um we started a poker game many
many years ago at a pub in in New York
wow uh and some are like I said summer
in the biz some are not but it's it's um
it's been going for a while and you know
it you don't get there immediately it
kind of yeah it grows and some people
come into the circle and some fall out
some some you lose for what's that Gary
Busey was there yeah
Hey Joe I'd love to wear your face you
know Jerry his his smile is blinding
everyone it came in the room 10 minutes
before he arrived and then there's like
some that you lose you know literally
that are no longer here and that bonds
this group even more you lose to
addiction or other things and and so
these are tenants that like keep get the
hooks in deeper yeah you know and uh we
all of us kind of take solace and that
and bring it up like we bring it up
often how lucky you know we are to have
that um because it does
keep us or keeps me from like spinning
out of feeling like you know it's great
to have an incredible loving wife to
vent to and and parents that are still
with me and and my brother and but you
also want friends that that serve that
as well guy friends guy friends hard to
get yeah it's interesting the the poker
I wasn't surprised at all I was like I
bet this is a card game it's almost like
this concession you give or the
collective masculinity it's like you
know this is not a new point we'll Bond
but we'll also kill fish you know what I
mean or we'll Bond but we'll also and I
don't even mean this I mean this I was
just having a conversation about the the
virtues of masculinity and I was like
surgery is very masculine even if a
woman is doing it because we don't have
masculine energy it's very like going
and [__] get it out of there like and
and it's a cliche but when Val and I are
trying to figure out where to go for
dinner I like that I can fill that again
it's a an archetype but I can be the one
that goes like we're going there and
even if we hate it we're going to deal
with it like that's your choice or when
I go to Disneyland with my daughter
telling helping her by being this very
decisive we're going on this we're going
on this yeah then we're going to eat
then we're gonna leave you know yeah
like that again women I fell into that
too that's powerful stuff so when I say
the poker game is just giving the dog of
manhood and I don't mean bad dog I just
mean like yeah the like whatever it is
giving it a meaty bone to gnaw on so
that after it relaxes okay I'm gonna I'm
gonna play cards with you I'm gonna
which let's be real that means I'm gonna
humiliate someone every once in a while
yeah Bluff them and Destroy them yeah
it's all good stuff yeah it's all good
I'm not saying that's bad and while
we're doing while we're giving that side
of our personalities this concession I
can also access other dimensions of my
personality in my life like you said
someone died from addiction who can't
relate to that how many of us are even
if it's not narcotics are addicted to
things that are hurting us that's scary
yeah let's be here together let's be
here together and and the the card game
is the excuse yeah well it didn't it
began it's just the card game right and
then and then it grows and then and
obviously some of the people I knew a
little bit before the card game
um but others that I didn't know would
be brought in by someone I did know that
someone that I trust and you get to know
that person you know and um I had
another point but maybe it'll come uh
but yeah I feel like that's uh Missing
meaty bone was it something about the
meaty bone no the concession fishing
that's all right addiction someone dying
so someone in the group passed away yeah
I'm not trying to it's not that kind of
podcast but like that happened and that
was an empty seat at the game it was
filled
almost immediate it like it was just
lined up
we had a wait listing just came right
into it there wasn't a week where it was
empty oh I mean it was filled it's like
the you know sheet license at the Sofi
Stadium you know one leaves another one
comes right what's the Oscars you
literally had a seat filler someone came
in or in a dark way it's a hospital bed
think about that let me ask you this uh
or let me tell you this also
um I feel like
uh physical affection with your male
friends is also uh important yeah um
that I just feel like
it's so hard to kind of break down some
of these uh you know male roles and
again I know we're Treading Water that's
been tread treaded forever but it's it's
just a shame that affection and physical
affection specifically yeah between men
has to be sexualized always yeah and um
you know like to get a like just a hug
yeah from a male friend can I say
incredible
man hugs man hugs there's nothing like a
man there's nothing there's nothing
there's another one oh my God you smell
great I'm worried about like I was
worried about my pitch this one's okay
good that was good see don't see it
doesn't feel good it's firm and your
shoulders thanks feel like belts are
pretty good I'm just saying yeah yeah
but there is a
look I hug Val all the time it's like
it's like hugging a stress toy or
something she's so soft and she smells
like flowers that's nice oh yeah oh yeah
yeah that's my everything I'm agreeing
I'm like oh what a nice but if I could
hug Tony Robbins
he's something that you would put next
to a building that you could build
another story on that building he's
Giant and wide and stringy
I'm saying all this is a positive thing
I completely agree and how much of it
not to get too psychological are we
perhaps
replace or or
becoming the male affection that we
often craved when we were when we were
kids yeah because we grew up in the
[__] 80s have you seen the 80s Jesus
Christ it's all over the place these
stereotypes and animal phobias yeah yeah
yeah gay Panic yes gay Panic everything
was gay I'm from [__] Boston for
[__] sake yeah everything was gay
everything was tense every and and
everything was killer be killed which is
kind of what we're talking about there
was a very like get it don't let other
people take it like go right at least
that's what I received and there wasn't
a lot of male
tenderness no and there wasn't a lot of
I mean I used to have a joke about it I
I haven't thought about it in a while
but I used to stand like that like I put
my hand on my hip like a teapot and my
baseball coach told me not to do it
because men don't stand that way and and
even in the moment I I understood that
he was looking out for sure like I
wasn't sure [__] you yeah yeah but he
was just passing on what has been passed
to him which was like this like it's a
generation uh idea he so I actually I
really even in the moment think I
received it as like a pro tip like
thanks because I don't want to be
bullied right but I also was like why
can't I yeah do that yeah why can't boys
hold hands or what there's all these
things that are happening I mean little
kids the way that little girls hold
hands right it's okay right I was
actually gonna say you and I are talking
about trying to maintain male friendship
Meanwhile my wife Val I love this
conversation
up where we live prancing around a
maypole interlocked with her four
friends no one has a bra everyone's
jiggling around and then they sing
jiggle fast then they bleed into the
soil and Howl at the Moon they're doing
fine and we're over here going like at
least I hugged Joe today we're barely
keeping up I know barely keeping up we
have a lot of catching up to two the men
yeah about a lot of things how do I what
I was gonna say what how what are your
feelings about this with your son
oh I mean I'm trying to be as open and
Progressive with uh gender roles and all
of that and and my wife as well with
with Eli as much as we can you know as a
parent you know like you just fear that
you're gonna say the wrong thing or [__]
things up or uh you know mess things up
and not not really ruin a terrific Soul
you know yeah
um but I but so far I think we're doing
you know pretty good on terms and when
it comes to like this masculinity the
the virtues of masculinity although is
your child not by that's a very no uh
question no he's seven years old and
seems to be very heterosexual very boy
be very boy yeah I had a gender normally
I don't even know the term but I don't
either it seems to be uh
yeah yeah yeah it seems yeah so when it
comes to the very complicated mire of
like what parts of this
are great to pass on and what parts of
this are kind of like more conversations
I'm not trying to figure it out I just
yeah yeah you know the I mean the first
thing that you know we both try to teach
him is just empathy and kindness I think
that's just a straightforward way to do
and then in terms of um you know
physical stuff like you know personal
space it's it's important and like
that's also a concept that like many
children
a little bit yeah a little bit you know
he's the sweetest sweetest kid and it's
all it's never out of aggression it's
out of excitement and of course um and
so you know that's that's a hard thing
to navigate too because you don't want
to quash this wonderful spirit and yeah
you just want to just have them
understand the concept of do you
understand this is why Greek boys were
like wrestling yeah let's get these
[__] wrestling yeah get it let's get
it out of the system yeah
seem to need it yeah let's make the
Olympics that's right that's what it was
we got them they let them throw hammers
yeah and metal balls let them run around
the track for a while it's basically
have them jump over something the
Olympics yeah they'll sleep tonight
that's what that's what it is run them
out with the Olympics
[Music]
of the whole Greek population what are
we gonna do about these kids we gotta
create some events but it's a healthy
yeah funneling yeah your son is getting
in fate like I love we have a girl and
I'm rough AF with with Leela we're she's
Fierce and incredible right and she
loves getting tossed and frankly I do a
lot of the things I do with her to
little boys and they're [__] freaked
out yeah that sounds like I'm a total
weirdo but like maybe I'll flip somebody
and be like that hurt man I'm like I oh
I'm sorry I'm used to Leela who seems to
be impervious to pain yeah but like it's
interesting to I'm losing my train of
thought but it was just about like oh
the healthy funneling of like there
seems to be
this uh abundance of energy and desire
to knock into stuff right and that seems
to be what sports is like I feel like I
hope Leela gets into sports yeah even
though I never was into it I I think
sports are
um I love sports I'm a big sports fan
mainly um football and baseball and
soccer
um but I think what sports does for me
um a couple things in in Gatherings
functions where you don't know a lot of
people yeah it's a common denominator
yeah what'd you think of the Rams uh how
about that game but you know that I
still feel left out on that people are
like and it's very very helpful
especially when you're with you know
different with people with different
political uh feelings yeah opinions
because then you bypass that all
together that's right and talk about the
sports and uh that's right and and
there's like just a drama in it and a
history to it what I'm saying what's
that there's there's some uh Republicans
here there's some Democrats here and
everybody's just talking about the
Patriots and I'm like this is like a
peacekeeping it really is it's giving
the players concussions but everyone
here seems okay in terms of this room
it's helping we're winning we're yeah
we're winning here
um and yeah and um
uh yeah we uh was I gonna say oh yeah my
um I like sports I played Sports a
little bit when I was younger I was not
very good at them yeah um but love
playing it probably made you better once
you got hooked up with the boys of the
state there's there's something about
learning how to collaborate sure yeah
absolutely teamwork for sure but also
also when do I when to pass when to pass
sometimes you don't have it you're like
I'm gonna pass to this guy who's a silly
dancer
yeah yeah yeah yeah
um
yeah and so uh uh it's also helped um
we gained some confidence when I was
younger too Sports you know martial arts
yeah yeah yeah
um
I did uh
for a while oh yes very dangerous very
dangerous
I'm uh these feet are deadly uh 50
deadly favorite parts of uh Once Upon a
Time in Hollywood is when Bruce Lee goes
like if I kill somebody if my friends
are lethal weapons right if I kill
somebody if I fight somebody and
accidentally kill them I go to jail and
he's like yeah everybody goes to jail
that's called manslaughter
have you ever almost died
yeah
um yep sure did with uh with Ken Moreno
and not in the van yeah did you hear the
story did he tell that story yeah but I
want to hear you tell it oh I didn't I
didn't hear the whole episode almost die
story was in the van with Michael Ian
Black driving yeah and he fell asleep
yeah but tell it and I'll tell you where
you differ oh man all right well ah for
your listeners
um I apologize for going into this again
this is the first time we've had like
crossover we had crossover
um and Mike Showalter was also in the
van I'm sure he said that so it was four
of us um we were coming from I believe
uh New Orleans or Austin and uh I think
Ken had the first shift uh driving left
in the middle of the night he did not
shrink that night um the rest of us did
except for Mike black it wasn't it
doesn't drink and um and so the mics and
I slept Ken drove and then you know at 7
30 pulled over and and you know black
jumped in there
um I was sitting shotgun
and I remember
I remember being awoken to screaming and
bouncing around
um and it was me screaming
um never a good story when you're like I
heard screaming turns out it turns out
it was me and uh and and I I screamed
awake and then I saw uh because my seat
was reclined and I saw things going past
the window and I was bumping around and
the first I remember my first thought
was
what dumb shortcut is black taking like
what is he what is he doing like just an
off-road shortcut honestly like for a
millisecond and then a millisecond after
that I realized what happened I was
terrified and so we're we're we're we're
bouncing screaming everyone
but everyone must have I heard screaming
I think it might have been turns out it
might have been black when he woke up
and you know Ken was sleeping behind us
in the kind of row behind us and he was
up against the dashboard
um as we're going over shrubs and
through small fences wait he got tossed
to the front yeah so it was a 15
passenger van and he was in that row
that seat row right behind the two front
seats laying down sleeping and so he
kind of just went forward and so he now
he's on the dash now he's on the dash
between me and Mike getting bumped
around and like you know and at least
you got some male affection he got male
affection finally and we all talked
about it and you're grabbing him and
loving it I am grabbing why does it have
to be
this way it doesn't mean anything Kevin
I just don't want you to go through the
window yeah
same shelter's on the ground and the
back is in the back row um
we finally come to a stop
um we had just gone off the road just
before Ravine
um so it really could have been really
really bad if I run for president my
campaign will be fill the Ravine filter
these remains for let's spackle up the
Grand Canyon these are just killing
people these are killing me let's fill
in the hole with [__] feed Holmes vote
me for president I'll fill all the holes
drain the swamp fill the holes that's
right I'm openly cheating on my way and
then I point to the camera none of this
Monica wins and then a bing on your
teeth yeah we
um we uh let's see black got out of the
car out of the van and started to do uh
circled the uh the van for damage now
the front axle is completely smashed and
the there's kind of barbed wire across
the spider web splintered uh windshield
the rear views or the side view mirrors
are gone
and he comes up to the window after a
walk around he's like you know guys it's
really not that bad
yeah he was being serious but he was in
shock shock as we all were
um Showalter at the time we all were
well Ken wasn't and Mike wasn't but uh
show off and I were smokers and he kind
of was just asking me for a cigarette
and he kept asking like Joe do you have
a cigarette do you have a cigarette from
the back and I'm I'm fine like Mike I
everything in the van is all over the
place I don't know where my cigarettes
are you know and so there was all this
panic and shock um we had rented the car
from MTV uh and we're like you they were
thinking about that
um a guy had seen us go off the road as
soon as we started going off the road
and he called
um the cops and the police in the
ambulance were there almost immediately
by the time we stopped it was really
quick and uh
not immediately but like within within
five minutes yeah like around the corner
right on the corner yeah they
the emery is that they were there super
quick
um and uh you know it was like Buford T
justice getting out of his trooper car
with the mirror sunglasses and hey boys
doing like it was that I'm like oh my
God are we in trouble and and he was
really
you know he was he was really it's
daytime he has the flashlight right yeah
he's been dragon
um he was very uh helpful and not at all
I I think he knew kind of what happened
because it was like 7 30 in the morning
and I think it was apparent that someone
fell asleep so he didn't get the third
degree he asked if everyone was okay we
it can we put Ken in the ambulance just
to check his back
um we stayed overnight in the hospital
in El Paso Texas
um and um and that was how we almost
died on on uh in a van look I don't mean
anything
but yeah I feel like that was a better
telling of the story oh did he get more
did I get more details yeah you got a
lot more details and yeah because I
remember when Ken told it it was very
casual but Kenny if you see this it was
beautiful but yeah it was very sort of a
matter of fact and you you kind of went
back there and the Kent rolls up at the
top well yeah no it was he didn't
mentioned that he rolled to the top I
don't think did he he did yeah he he um
I mean it was a it was a truly
it was a truly obviously scary moment
but one that actually stayed with me in
my body for years in that years later
um even five years later maybe not that
much let's say within two I would if I
was sleeping in a car yeah like not
driving obviously riding or in a plane
and there was turbulence yeah I would
startle awake yeah and you know the PTSD
of that event stayed with me for a while
you know that's and uh there's similar
themes that go on in this horror movie
that I just wrote and directed and
um and and it's it's because the body
keeps the score it's a great book by
that title and I'm forgetting the author
um and it's true and like all this stuff
that you can't handle or is too much
your your body goes all right I'll take
it you don't have to think about it I'm
gonna hold it yep uh until you get it
out it's gonna be here and um I was just
gonna say there's certain my friend went
to a that's magic mine
you're gonna love it
there's no downside that's all I'll say
you'll just you'll just love it
um she went to a it's not like Reiki or
anything but he's sort of an intuitive
sort of massagy sort of like whatever
and he's going over your body and going
what's this this was when yeah it's when
you're the seven uh something what
happened when you were seven sort of
like a friend of a psychic and a
masseuse yep and that's a fine story
anybody can claim that they're finding
things on your body and saying how old
were you when this happened yeah maybe
something happened and you leave with
kind of like a magic show feel but after
he did this work on her where he wasn't
even touching her he was just finding
spots maybe applying some pressure but
nothing major and and talking about what
happened at a certain age a certain year
she sits up after like 90 minutes of
this and he goes just so you know a lot
of my uh patients sometimes get a little
nauseous afterwards so just drink some
water be patient with yourself the rest
of the day just recognize that it might
not seem like we did anything but we did
yeah and she's driving home she had like
a 90 minute drive home and in the middle
of the drive just starts like Exorcist
puking everywhere whoa so I'm like that
is still yeah in your thing and the
times people give the Reiki rake I don't
know why I looked at Katie but Reiki
gets uh are you saying Ricky she's a
real naysayer it's an easy target you're
gonna have your hands over me but the
times that I've gone and and they find
something just something tight something
blocked yeah and they they're not in my
body and I'm like that is tight and
blocked and you're just hovering over me
I'm we were talking about uh yoga or
yogurt as I like to call you um earlier
and they were you know I I a while back
when I was doing it more regularly
I I was in a position where it's almost
like a split like it was stretching my
hips it was like some weird thing where
my hips were kind of up and out yeah and
on a block uh yeah I think it might have
been on the Block I I just started
bawling yeah bowling like not like oh
this is like
crying like what my hips what's and it's
true it it all it's all there it's like
a river and all of those things can get
stuff moving get stopped up and what I
it's one of the weirdest I just wish it
was a little bit more culturally
normalized because as we're talking
about it I always go like I gotta I
gotta do more stuff like that yeah but
like I do wish it was just kind of part
of integrated into Western medicine
we're like Hey Joe uh you said you had
that weird thing look it's not gonna
hurt I think and your insurance covers
it you should go talk to be great well
kimbi Nando Joe and what kimbi is gonna
lay his hands on your shoulders and
compliment your scent that's what I did
I I you know I think that's a smart
approach I wish I wish that was true I
wish we had more of that I I relate to
what you're saying with the with the
emotions from certain yoga poses it kind
of it kind of gets back to you know
really
trying to take care of yourself like I'm
gonna kind of just briefly swing into a
little bit about mental health yeah like
and I'm I'm thinking
in particular of the the senator from
Pennsylvania that uh fetterman I think
that checked himself in
um to did you know about this he um he
had depression and was looking into it
and uh and I just thought as a public
figure that was pretty brave uh to do
especially I get why a lot of people are
like what are you doing man why'd you
become a politician and you know like
what did you think was going to happen
and and
okay I mean I understand why people
would feel that but like the main
takeaway is like here's a guy that's
trying to take care of himself yeah you
know and um I just wish there was a
little bit more patience with uh with
that mental health is yeah physical
health it yeah it's so much so that like
I've said this a million but I think
it's a helpful image it's like when
people end their own lives it's helpful
to think that that's it's it's the same
as a tumor you know what I mean it's
like a it's a thought tumor yeah it's
something that that needed treatment
even though it's ethereal it's not
physical like a tumor but these things
are physical health and they can be life
and death issues yeah but I still might
I went to therapy for years and my
father would still deny it that's just
generational not mad about it but you've
never been to the therapy right I'm like
why is where are you yeah for you it's
it's uh you know I found it helpful you
know Beth and I go and I mean therapy in
general is just uh I think and I had a
stigma with it for a while as well I
don't know for sure being Irish Italian
or just well the only uh race that's
impervious to therapy According to Freud
is the Irish yeah but but I came around
and realized you know it's super so you
go with your way I do and so it's
technically I have gone solo before I'm
currently not in but we'll certainly
return because I I like kind of checking
in uh uh every now and then with with
with myself oh with myself and going yep
you know by myself to therapy yeah but
that is that something that helps your
relationship as well sure for sure yeah
yeah it's interesting I was just
watching the office where they were
talking about couples therapy and
they're like you're really there to talk
to one another like the guy yeah that's
yeah I think that's fairly true right
yeah I think having well Val and I do
the podcast together I know this is
going to sound silly but having a
dedicated time where we just talk to one
another yeah about our feelings about
our lives
and I I roll I roll my eyes because it's
just insane Leela goes to school so
she's at school you'd think that would
be when we catch up but that's when we
have to cram in any work right yeah any
friend or any exercise or anything and
it's gone before you know it you're
picking up Leela she's the light of my
life I love her to death but
I I I don't know why I'm giving advice
to people that didn't ask for it but
they can't they're the listeners um
having I know some people have date
nights I'm just like just a coffee like
we're gonna talk for one hour I think
that's a great that's a great point or
even that's a great point because
sometimes date night is hard to manage
where it's too much even even a half
hour even 20 minutes yeah yeah like like
it's it's I think it's the moment of
like hey you've got my undivided and
what's going on let's put our phones in
a drawer yeah I think it saves a lot of
problems uh hopefully that are coming up
all right let's see I think we're not
funny enough on this podcast oh we
haven't been funny for 20 years
we haven't even tried to be fun by the
way I suffer here's something I suffer
from imposter syndrome and and not good
enough
great thanks
I think you're doing fantastic
it's being open it's being open Buster
syndrome's a rough one yeah
yeah
just be yeah yeah it's just it's just
that it yeah like uh though I mean I
think everyone can relate to like
they're gonna find me out sooner or
later that it's not yeah I'm not really
as interesting or talented or good as as
all my work says I wonder if it's a
comfort to know that every maybe
everybody sort of feels that way yeah I
remember mullaney told me a story about
when he started writing for SNL somebody
gave him a notebook like that said
Saturday Night Live on it yeah
um and they were I wish I knew who it
was because it's really their story but
he leaned into Johnny was like I know
what you're thinking I'm a fraud right
like or like some version yeah yeah yeah
they're gonna figure me out right he's
like we all feel that way yeah I think I
think that's true yeah yeah
I know there there's a lot of people
that have it it's hard I don't want to
out anybody but I know other people in
the business that have it and it seems
like a drag is it a drag I I I feel like
I don't it doesn't
um [__] me and it it just it's
another kind of feeling sometimes it
doesn't dominate me at all like you know
it's often after I get a job or after
something comes out or I'm like I don't
know you know and but it's fleeting uh
you know it's it like I said it hasn't
really kept me
um from really kind of enjoying what I
have done and the things that you know
at what point is it healthy yeah I mean
the green light and I'm just showing
like the opposite of this is like of
course you hired the great Joe La Julian
right right right no maybe this is why
you're learning your lines maybe yeah
it's kind of a preparation thing for
sure yeah thank you it's like coming
into this podcast being like do I
deserve it am I interesting enough to
talk about for two hours yeah I I think
given the alternative being like you're
welcome yeah like some 19 year old
YouTube store that's just like you get
to talk to me about the time I shave my
nuts on camera tell me about that get
out of here [__] get out of here
um well I I have my speed round which I
think you're going to enjoy but we can
also talk a little bit
um I only say a little bit because
there's no pressure about the meaning of
life
um
I'm just taking a moment to remember
that this is life this is it yeah you're
really weird yeah do you ever have that
feel I get that feeling all the time
where I'm like this is the mystery we're
all talking this is the mystery that
confounded Plato right Play-Doh was like
what he was thinking this too yes like
what is and it's this it's this moment
yeah we're in it every you know usually
happens in the morning I wake up or in
the middle of the night I'll pee or
something and I'm like oh right it's
yeah this I still haven't figured this
out and I don't think I ever will
exactly figure it out right but do you
have any
sign posts anything that's helping you
not freak out oh
um
I try to
I try to keep my actions in life toward
um again we talked about a little about
creating things but also
um understanding
that your time is limited
um like as far as the meaning of life
you know I
at a young age I remember imagining I
was getting existential like like seven
eight years old be like what if it was
just like it's all black like I'm but
I'm not even here but I'm not even
thinking that I'm not here because I'm
not here like I was pretty early on
thinking of seven yeah like or that's my
memory of it anyway
um you know maybe it was a little bit
older but but
you know so I've always
um what my point is in terms of that uh
can I join you on that I remember
thinking when I was around the same age
being like what if I'm the only one
that's real
which is weird because the more I go
into uh it's Buddhism and Hinduism it's
like there is only one mind I I
misinterpreted that intuition that I am
the only that Pete is the only one
that's real and Joe disappears you're
not looking at him but then there are
all these ancient Traditions that that
point to the idea that like
that was a Mis articulation of the idea
that we're all sharing the same being
yeah right yeah and I would add to that
saying like part of
um as I get older the meaning of life is
finding those connections yeah just
finding those connections at where it
they're all there you know I mean I
you know maybe this may not be popular
uh but I I just believe that we're Ash
and dust and so I feel like it's
important to live life
um
Without Regrets to make sure that the
people that you care about and you love
they know it
um that you leave something
um it leaves something behind that's
better than how you left it like all of
these all of these all of these things
um bury your poop don't leave any Trash
yeah I mean it's true like I think I
said in my in my memo I'm like talk
about cleaning up your own [__] because
yeah really I honestly that's weird and
yeah it's I'll show you and I'm like
because this is a good thing I'm talking
about stuff to talk about with you and
and you know it's so important to me
like even if you know someone's not
gonna step in it clean it up yeah yeah
and you know I'm weird I've never done
the camping metaphor but there is
something about leaving it better and
not making a mess that is and even if
you can't leave it leave it better if
you leave a mess clean it up yeah that
that's the main that's the main thing um
okay your Ash and dust thing is
it might not be
religion at its deeper levels would
agree with you even though that seems
Bleak well I want to add to that though
because I be I mean I am an atheist but
I also do know that I am not in total
control yeah sure there is a higher
power and
um you just and I don't know and I don't
I don't know I hope something is out
there but for me to kind of really dig
my heels into life I need to feel like
this is it like this is all we have and
so let's make it right and um
your world view would lock you into the
juice of your experience so for you not
having the easy answer of a deity or
whatever it might be but yeah rather
saying I don't know but I know that I'm
impermanent it's very Buddhist to be
honest I I thanks yeah yeah I just want
you to feel less alone I because thank
you Buddhism is very it's non-theistic
it doesn't claim a God and it claims
that it's important to remember that
you're that you're gonna die certain
other religions have it as well Saint
Francis called his body his corpse it
was just this way of reminding himself
that like this is briefly animated
corpse the gnostics were very hard on
were you uh were you raised a certain
religion I was Raising Evangelical
Christian like a fundamental okay I say
fundamentalists but not true not uh that
can get pretty nuts I just mean
literalists we believed the Bible to be
literal for the most part I yeah which
is pretty tricky icky sticky sure sure
um at least that's how I took it I I I'd
be curious if I really with my adult
brain now interviewed yeah my pastor
yeah when I was growing up if he would
have said that the creation story for
example was poetry I said not literal he
probably would have if I had to guess
but what I took from it was
because it was there were the leaders
but then they were just like us the
congregants right and we were like a
tribe going for certainty and going for
answers and so we kind of had our own
self-propagated uh fundamentalism even
if the church wasn't itself I see okay
so yeah so I've had to show by the way I
feel I just I like want to be clear that
I think faith is very important yeah and
I think
um a belief in God or Christ or whatever
is important for some and I think you
know I and you know it's not for me per
se but like it's something that I would
uh defend well it's interesting because
you're you're saying higher power or
mystery right which by the way you're in
good company there's a lot of atheists I
don't think you've betrayed your atheism
at all you're just saying I do not
have a certain feeling about a God that
other people seem to have yeah and that
is not your world view but it reminds me
of how
um in the Hebrew tradition you wouldn't
write the name of God right so you're
actually taking that so far as to say
like I'm not even gonna name this thing
right right right the Big Bang
erupted right like the universe
sprung into life yeah and you have such
reverence I'm putting words in your
mouth for that mystery that you're like
I'm not even gonna name the dude that
did it but I am going to have humility
and I'm gonna recognize I'm a part of it
and I'm a fleeting part of it absolutely
I just yes that's that's exactly it and
and
yeah yeah
to that the only reason
I always want my atheist friends to have
some comfort when it comes to death
being the big black nothing and I've
talked about this a million but it's
like don't forget the universe erupted
out of a big black nothing that's right
you know what I'm saying so it's like
you go into your origin right like you
came out of a black nothing you go into
a big black nothing so don't be afraid
of the thing that birth yeah yeah I
think that's a great so there's hope for
everybody there's hope yes yes and I
appreciate you finding that well that's
what I'm saying too yeah when Dr Drew
I've mentioned this many times about
when Dr Drew this podcast he's been with
a lot of people is they're dying and
he's like I'll tell you I wish I
believed in God because the people that
do tend to do better as they're dying
I'm like you don't have to have a god
you need to have a reverence for a
system this is a cliche that's larger
than you yeah and that's that's what I
mean which which I which I have and also
like again this is about like living
your life out is true to yourself then I
feel like I've I've done I've done it
I've I did my purpose I don't I don't I
I I've been as truthful as I can to the
spirit that is that's right you know I
ran with the ball and he strapped on a
big old fat fake ding dong favorite
movies oh you know I I did you write
that down no but I wanted to bring you
uh the script I wanted to give you and
I'm gonna get it to you yeah I'm gonna
get it to you and because it's just in
my kind of office did you know it's one
of my favorite movies I did Carrie or
Kenneth told me and and um that's
amazing yeah oh I'd love to read it yeah
I'd love to have it you could have it
we'll give it to you give it to you does
it mention your huge hug
uh so we shot that um in Georgia and uh
in context of this movie wander that's
where Joe plays a naked hip-hop nudist
thank you yes and you wear a prosthetic
I wear a prosthetic penis and um I'm
meeting the special effects guy uh for
the first time
um to to uh just meet him and because
he's going to be putting on this
Appliance on a special purpose quite
intimate with me so we meet uh at an at
an Applebee's like in Athens Georgia
somewhere I'm good in the neighborhood
and we go to the Applebee's and we are
talking about our love for horror movies
and and then it's it's kind of like a
drug deal I'm like all right so you got
the piece where you got the piece and he
goes he goes it's in the car so we go
out so we go out to the car okay
he gets in the driver's seat I sit I sit
shotgun it's in a shoe box
and
we're just alone it's it's just alone
it's just yeah it's just alone and now
this really does feel like uh an illicit
drug deal or something elicit is
happening and I guess in a way it was
are you a cop and um are you a car are
you a cop person and I and I open up now
also at this uh the movie I'd done
before was in uh independent movie that
never came out but I was playing a um
a transgender
um and I was going through transition
and so I had shaved my chest and he was
saying you know you're going to be a
nudist we may have to put some hair on
your chest can I see your chest as well
so in the car I'm I'm I have my shirt up
and I'm holding the fake penis and I'm
looking at it and I'm like all that
needs now is the Georgia Trooper to
component right next to it
yeah how we doing today Justice again
and um ran off the road and now this
um it's Thomas Landing in a short but he
doesn't know he doesn't know me it's
actually the kids
um anyway that was uh the first meeting
of uh Toby sells gentleman's name it was
great um and uh he gave me the ding dong
I don't know where it is
um I think you know I think it's
property of universal it's not a Planet
Hollywood yeah
[Music]
you go to Planet Hollywood there it is a
Mormon family goes to Planet Hollywood
I've been waiting for their whole lives
and they get sad at the latrulio table
with the ding dong it was very fun
playing that role it was fun walking
around in a in a robe for the whole time
everyone I've talked to about that movie
because one of the things that I love
about it is is uh it speaks to how we
would be doing better if we would just
be together if that was a value yeah
instead of these rectangles that we all
hide from each other in it's nice the
hippies are on to something in fact they
didn't make it up that's right the
Native Americans lots of different
cultures have been a little bit more
forced proximity and it can be really
beautiful and also that movie skewer is
just exactly how it can go wrong yeah as
well but when you're shooting a movie
even if it's not a movie about forced
Community a movie itself is a forced
community so if you're in a forced
community of a movie doing a movie about
a forced Community you've got that
experience a little bit Yeah you got to
be it was a great day I loved making the
movie and there was that that uh vibe
Bond set too we all had like our houses
and we'd have parties after and it was
it was a lot of fun my parents visited
that set and uh you know when I walked
out with my prosthetic they're in video
Village and everyone in video Villages
they were sitting in the back and just
kind of like turned to see what their
reaction was like they got a kick out of
it um and you're dead they were thrilled
to meet Jennifer
yeah right
of course they were thrilled to meet
Jennifer oh man and she was a sweetheart
as she's known to be I'm sure she would
be I'm sure it was great it was a good
time
um well that that covers the the the pot
I think that's a great story to end on
we always do one laugh moment for the
God moment but you did it on your own oh
unless you want to tell me the time you
laughed the hardest in your life but I I
do okay please do it's short um I mean
it's uh so this happened recently
because I was thinking about this too uh
unlike the last story this one's short
short joke
oh there you go
uh my wife and I uh it's at the end of
the night we're kind of um uh we're in
bed we're reading
no she I'm sorry she is now gone to
sleep but I'm not tired yet but I'm
hungry and I and I I bring these this
big bag of old school tortilla chips
like the thick kind of like the really
you know with a set like a thick
cellophane bag
and so it's just I'm opening it's crazy
she's drunk it's so loud and I'm like I
finally get the chip and then and then
the chicken and then just
and this I get through like three three
chips and like she just starts laughing
and it's like are you kidding me are you
and she's laughing and I start laughing
because we're both acknowledging how
we're I'm trying to be square it's
impossible to be quiet
um and it was a great great laugh
that is such a great marriage lab
that is so something I would do and you
but you don't give up what I love about
it is you didn't give up the bag is too
loud I'm gonna of course chip it's too
loud
because I went to different parts of my
teeth I'm like I crunched on this part
it was loud maybe if I in the front what
if I kind of sucked the salt off and
make it a little bit soggier but then
you're hearing
oh and none of it worked this is
everything
it reminds me of I was in a meeting a
student government meeting in college
and I was eating a brownie and my
roommate Chuck was watching me this
Brownie and I was done with the Brownie
and but they were a little there were
some crumbs yeah and I started
um I don't know if I wet my finger but
it was a pretty moist brush I could just
push on the crumb and put it in my mouth
he watched this whole thing happen a fly
land I swapped the fly
10 seconds later I look I see the fly I
think it's a brownie I push it I pretty
much get it in my mouth oh but it makes
it even better that he was watching the
whole time like things like that he
didn't know anyone I didn't know anyone
was watching he watched and he knew when
I killed the fight he was like that
Dingus is gonna think that's a piece of
brownie and I did it got in my mouth and
I was like
like that amazing food like hunger being
such a need your story and those stories
are my favorite that was that was a
great answer good well and I'm so glad
we want to say thank you for having me
yes of course and uh I think you're so
you're terrific at what you do man and
and your podcast is very uh uh open and
funny and true and human I appreciate
that yeah it was wonderful that you that
you were there for it you know what I
mean I'm always trying to get this exact
vibe that we had oh good but and
sometimes it's not the other person's
fault but that's not their frequency but
we got there immediately yeah and this
flew by and you're a delight and thank
you and what's the name of your movie
It's called Outpost and uh we'll be uh
released in May of 2023. okay we're very
very excited very very good yeah
congratulations thank you man would you
say keep it crispy it's just how we end
sure
keep it crispy
after two hours of not mispronouncing a
word after you said sometimes you do
when you do podcasts it would have been
great if you were like crunch stick
toasty
crunched a toasty pepper we had a lot
remember the riffs you're gonna drive
home and you're gonna remember I know
and you'll be proud I hope so and you'll
go imposter no more ah yeah yes thanks
buddy all right bye-bye bye
[Music]